not only is Christmas not a month-long
event that occurs in December it's
called Advent that's that's what happens
during December Christmas also is not
just one day it's just amazing how this
is a misconception in the culture but it
drives me crazy because we don't have
any of the the right timing for anything
anymore and we want to rush everything
so we want to celebrate Christmas before
Thanksgiving in some cases and everybody
wants to celebrate Christmas right after
Thanksgiving all the way through
December and then they want to stop
celebrating Christmas on December 26th
Christmas is a season Christmas is 12
days that's why we have the song The 12
Days of Christmas that's why we have the
play Twelfth Night 12th night by
Shakespeare which refers to the end of
that Christmas season on Eve of epiphany
and then you celebrate the Epiphany and
then we go on and then there's more and
then you celebrate Easter at Easter and
you celebrate the 4th of July at the 4th
of July and you celebrate Christmas on
Christmas